est ce que je peux dire quelque chose
qui peut choquer qui n'engage que moi
bien sûr alesi très bien alors je vous
le dirai ça n'engage que moi et j'espère
des janves le comprendront parce
qu'évidemment je suis très touché par
tout ce qui est tout ce qui se fait en
fonction
et c'est vrai que mathieu je vous dis
depuis quelques jours vous êtes
extrêmement touché par ce qui se passe
oui je vous sens et mathieu je peux le
dire à la dhr je peux dire un peu de
tout des choses je vous si vous êtes
alors on se l'est tu faisais tous les
jours au téléphone
ouais je trouve que vous êtes vraiment
un amour parce que vraiment vous allez
toujours avec moi on m'appelait tous les
jours moi j'étais prendre de haut niveau
évidemment aussi tous les jours et joue
sent très seul dans cette situation un
peu de confinement et voilà je j'ai
l'impression que vous avez envie aussi
d'aider les autres de devoir la dédiant
encore plus les autres avec ce qui se
passe et je me sens extrêmement touchée
oui c'est très doué mais aussi parce que
vous êtes très seul en ce moment très
triste parce que je là je veux parler
pour moi je parle pour beaucoup de gens
qui sont comme moi évidemment quand on a
une famille quand on travaille quand on
a des amis quand on est des enfants
alors tout d'un coup j'appelle ma soeur
belle se confine avec ses enfants à la
raison j'appelle un ami se combine avec
son copain vous votre famille et vos
enfants
jlf à tous et c'est vrai que quand on
travaille beaucoup alors c'est aussi
deux gars 06 beaucoup ce cas aussi
notamment chez les homosexuels tout ça
mais c'est pas là ce n'est pas le cas ce
cas là mais ça que quand on travaille
tout d'un coup et que tu ne cours se dit
bah quand sa frappe fort et qu'elle un
confinement
c'est ça ben on se confondent affi qui
ont acquis ben voilà alors moi c'est pas
bien j'ai déjà les voitures de sport et
j'ai beaucoup travaillé mais quand le
confinement arrive on fait un petit plan
sur sa vie et puis on se dit que
peut-être coupable de quelque chose
aussi de david se passe à côté quelque
chose mais je suis seul
alors les sols est confiné et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont seuls beaucoup
jean michel et seul aussi pour sûrement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont seuls et
je pense avant beaucoup à eux parce
qu'il ya la maladie mais aussi tout ce
que ça va entraîner derrière et ça tue
très inquiet pour ça jimmy mohamed le
disais tout à l'heure on fait très
attention à ce qu'ils aient pas de cas
de suicides à ce qu'ils aient pas de cas
de dépression
un jour qu'ils sont seuls chez eux qui
n'ont plus rien à faire et qui en plus
se disent je en train de perdre
peut-être mon travail mon argent et
qu'ils sont seuls
c'est très très difficile moi j'ai bien
sûr j'ai de la chance dans tout ça mais
oui bien sûr ça me touche
est ce que j'aurais adoré et j'espère je
vais pas me faire insulter que je vais
le dire je vais le dire avec des mots
plus simples
enfin moi pardon parce que c'est toi là
c'est le truc qui va là c'est le truc
qui va nous choquer l'actuel nom whisky
ou choqué c'est que j'étais médecin
l'autre jour qui dit qui disait donc
c'est pas moi lorsqu'il ya une épidémie
aussi violente et deux façons de faire
soit effectivement on se confine pendant
des mois et des mois et on tue
totalement l'économie les taux de
suicide augmente les dépressions
augmente et on rentre dans une
dépendance d'une dans une crise
économique qui va durer dix ans soit on
décide de l'affronter comme l'a fait
l'angleterre
ils ont changé d'avis en langue ouais
enfin on peut tous sortir attrapé le
virus
et puis peut-être décidé qu'il y aura
des morts en angleterre il avait parlé
de 20 milles qu'il y aura des morts mais
qu'au bout de trois semaines
une fois que tout le monde qu'on aura
passé les 50 % de contaminer l'équipe
l'épidémie va mourir je ne dis pas que
c'est la bonne solution mais je dis
qu'effectivement il aurait peut-être pu
avoir un référendum pour que nous
français on décide c'est notre vie c'est
notre santé on aurait peut-être pu
décider
on va rentrer dans une crise économique
incroyable et là c'est un petit peu mot
domaine sup à jimmy moreno médecine mais
en tout cas en économie en effet huit
ans la suite de ça ça va être quoi
une récession économique gigantesque la
banque fédérale est en train de sortir
d'un mais alors jamais non mais quand on
va dire elle allie vie humaine passe
avant les couilles mais j'entends bien
sûr les mairies vies humaines de toute
façon quand vous regardez maintenant les
spécialistes parlent alors ça change
tout le temps entre deux cent mille
trois cent mille morts en france
peut-être peut-être 400 milles au pic de
norvégien on n'avait rien fait voilà
rien n'avait rien je reviens de combien
gilles si on n'avait rien voir beaucoup
moins on l'espère ya pas de chiffons
l'espère à tire larigot l'espère mais on
navigue à vue
je pense qu'on aurait dû expliquer tout
ça avec des spécialistes et malgré tout
demandé aux français leur avis il s'agit
quand même de leur santé de leur pays et
de leur économie derrière mais je pense
qu'on aurait pu nous demander notre je
ne dis pas que j'aurais choisi ça je
veux juste qu'on m'explique les choses
et que je puisse décider il s'agit quand
même de nous et de notre vie et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent aussi comme
ça et si l'angleterre a hésité ils sont
pas plus bêtes que nous l'ont plus
anglais donc je pense qu'on aurait sur
un référendum et en parler et là
effectivement odeurs je me suis énervé
ces cours nous infantiliser on nous
culpabilise tel restaurant tu es sorti
dans l'art mais t'as pas fait ce qu'on
te dit chez toi confiné on nous
culpabilise alors que pardon la maladie
elle vient pas de nous un dans les
adieux
mathieu là vous choisissez l'économie
contre l'être humain avr aip massinon
peux pas vous laisser dire ça comme
cyril ledit l'angleterre revient en
arrière ils sont en train de confiner
toutes les personnes âgées
ils ont peur d'une hécatombe l'opinion
va se révolter bientôt boris johnson va
être en difficulté on peut pas faire ça
et
ce que vous dites n'est pas acceptable
non plus c'est que vous parlez d'un
référendum vous imaginez là aujourd'hui
les gens à aller voter pour un référé du
sipal en arriver aux arrêts ou et ans là
où sera la poubelle le retard est donc
on peut pas ajouter un référendum non
moi je trouve franchement qu'aujourd'hui
l'heure n'est pas à la polémique
politicienne vous pouvez pas dire ça
aujourd'hui on a fait un choix qui est
de tenter de limiter la propagation avec
un confinement de quinze jours qui va
sans doute très certainement être
renouvelée on disait tout à l'heure et
c'est normal et on ne peut pas il faut
sauver le plus de vies humaines ce qui
on le sait une vie humaine pour moi vaut
mille récession mondiale
on sauve une vie je me fous des
récessions et on dirait que tu vas
perdre tout en argent toutes les
économies mais si j'osais au vu de tous
ces jeunes soldats choisi pour l'instant
elle ne sort pas non plus les six mais
ces belles qu'on parle déjà loué c'est
la meilleure solution pour l'alliance
est resté confiné à son héros sans doute
cyril mais jeudi qu' on aurait pu en
parler il y aurait pu avoir un débat et
sorhaitz aurait pu mais rien n'avait
conseil de l or est ce qu'on n'a pas le
temps on n'a pas le temps m'a tuer
d'autrui par l'apec temps parce que te
rappelle que pendant trois semaines on a
un gouvernement qui a dit et c'est rien
c'est à rien et bien à gaza était pareil
dans le monde entier regarde
l'angleterre en garde un peu partout
regarde l'italie
ils ont des pas et voilà les italiens et
pas plus compte c'est vrai voilà c'est
pas forcément ça est un peu pareil
partout en chine aussi est vrai sont
fait prendre par le virus et eux ils ont
voilà ils ont ils ont construit des
hôpitaux assez rapidement cetera
mais aussi ils ont été en confinement
assez vite un régime il faudra en tirer
les leçons
mais plus tard mais plus tard et il ya
un politique aujourd'hui kippour - dit
n'importe quoi c'est agnès buzyn qui
était miné de la santé candidat à paris
qui dit maintenant dans une interview au
monde
ces élections c'était une mascarade
quand j'ai démissionné je savais ce qui
allait arriver
je savais que le tsunami sanitaire
allait survenir mais madame busin gl10
aussi j'ai averti bien avant le 11
janvier manuel macro mais madame buzancy
vous le saviez
il fallait d'abord resté au ministère de
la santé quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il
arrive pour nous sauver pour aider les
personnels de santé qui en avait bien
besoin à s'organiser
il fallait pas partir et on dit pas ça
aujourd'hui on crée pas de polémique
aujourd'hui mais elle veut dire quoi
je trouve qu'elle se dédouane les files